>> Tucker: THEY ARE INVISIBLE
IN WASHINGTON COME ON, AND BY
THE OFFICIAL UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS THAT YOU HEAR ON
TELEVISION, YET THEY'RE
EVERYWHERE.
AMERICANS THAT HAVE DROPPED OUT
OF THE WORKFORCE, WORKERS WHO
DON'T WORK.
AN EVER INCREASING PERCENTAGE OF
THESE ARE MALE.
ABOUT 7 MILLION AMERICAN MEN
BETWEEN THE AGES OF 25 AND 54 NO
LONGER HAVE JOBS.
THAT'S MORE THAN 10% OF THE
ENTIRE PRIME AGE MALE LABOR
FORCE IN THE UNITED STATES.
AS A HUGE NUMBER.
MOST OF THOSE STUDIES PREDICT
MEN WILL NEVER RETURN TO WORK.
WHAT HAPPENED?
SOME OF THE CAUSES ARE
WELL-KNOWN.
COMPETITION FROM FOREIGN
MANUFACTURERS CRUSHED OUR
COUNTRY'S INDUSTRIAL SECTOR.
CHINA'S ENTRY INTO THE WTO ALONE
DESTROYED AMERICAN JOBS.
A DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
THESE JOBS ARE IN TRADITIONALLY
MALE INDUSTRIES.
OUR 2016 McKINSEY REPORT FOUND
THAT "90% OF THE ELDERS,
CUTTERS, SOLDERS JOBS COULD BE
REPLACED BY ROBOTS AND WOULD BE
SOON."
THREE OF THE FIVE FASTEST
GROWING PROFESSIONS ARE
DOMINATED BY WOMEN.
THE JOBS THAT REMAIN FOR MEN
TEND TO PAY LESS THEN THE ONCE
DISAPPEARED.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR
WORKING-CLASS MEN WHO UNLIKE
THEIR FEMALE COUNTERPARTS HAVE
SEEN THEIR REAL WAGES FALL OVER
THE TIME.
THE REAL REASON FOR THAT IS MASS
IMMIGRATION.
MORE THAN A MILLION NEW
IMMIGRANTS ENTER THIS COUNTRY
EVERY YEAR ILLEGALLY.
A LARGE BUT UNKNOWN NUMBER,
ILLEGALLY.
ALL OF THEM ARE LOOKING FOR
WORK.
THESE NEW ARRIVALS COMPETE
PRIMARILY WITH THE VERY
AMERICANS MOST LIKELY TO HAVE
LOST THEIR JOBS AND THE EFFECT
IS LOWER WAGES.
IT'S A MATTER OF SUPPLY AND
DEMAND.
AN OVERABUNDANCE OF ANYTHING
MAKES IT CHEAPER AND THAT GOES
FOR LABOR.
ONE STUDY CONDUCTED IN FLORIDA
FOUND AMERICANS WITH LOWER
EDUCATION LEVELS IN MIAMI, THE
MOST VULNERABLE SAW THEIR WAGES
FALL BY 37% AFTER THE IMMIGRANTS
ARRIVE.
POLICYMAKERS DIDN'T SEEM TO
NOTICE AND THEY STILL DON'T,
PROBABLY BECAUSE DOESN'T AFFECT
THEM.
HOW LONG WITH THE BORDERS STAY
OPEN IF THESE PEOPLE WERE
BECOMING LAWYERS?
NOW THESE MEN ARE MAKING LESS
AND THEIR FATHERS.
AS A BETRAYAL OF THE AMERICAN
DREAM, BUT IT'S ALSO A RECIPE
FOR SOCIETAL COLLAPSE.
WHEN MEN'S WAGES DECLINE,
FAMILIES FELL APART.
THIS FACT IS WELL KNOWN TO
RESEARCHERS.
IT'S A SUBJECT OF MANY STUDIES
OVER THE DOCKETS WITH CONSISTENT
RESULTS.
YET IT'S REALLY NOTED IN PUBLIC.
HERE'S SOME OF WHAT WE KNOW.
ONE WELL-REGARDED STUDY FROM
LAST YEAR THAT WHEN MEN'S WAGES
FELL RELATIVE TO WOMEN'S,
FAMILIES DID IN FORM.
ACCORDING TO THE AUTHORS, A
FALLING MILL WAGE PRODUCED
INFERTILITY AND MARRIAGE RATES.
IN THE WORDS OF ONE OF THE
AUTHORS, AN ECONOMICS PROFESSOR
AT MIT "WE FIND A DECLINE IN
FERTILITY, MARRIAGE, BUT ARRIVES
IN A FRACTION OF BIRTHS THAT ARE
DISADVANTAGE AS A CONSEQUENCE,
THE KIDS ARE LIVING IN PRETTY
TOUGH CIRCUMSTANCE."
NUMEROUS ACADEMIC STUDIES HAVE
REACHED THE VERY SAME
CONCLUSION.
RESEARCH FROM 2015 FOUND THAT "A
RANDOMLY CHOSEN WOMAN BECOMES
MORE LIKELY TO EARN MORE THAN A
RANDOMLY CHOSEN MAN, MARRIAGE
RATES DECLINE.
THOSE WHO DO MARRY REPORT BEING
LESS SATISFIED AND ARE MORE
LIKELY TO DIVORCE.
LOW MAIL WAGES ARE A DRIVING
FORCE AND FAMILY DISSOLUTION AND
THAT'S WHY AFFLUENT
NEIGHBORHOODS IN WHICH MEN MAKE
MORE HAVE A HIGHER PROPORTION OF
MARRIED COUPLES AND FEWER
DIVORCES.
THE OPPOSITE IS ALSO TRUE AND
THAT LEADS TO A CASCADE OF
SOCIAL PROBLEMS WHICH OVER TIME
BECOME A DISASTER.
MEN WHO MAKE LOWER WAGES MARY
LES AND FATHER MORE CHILDREN OUT
OF WEDLOCK.
THESE CHILDREN GROWING UP
WITHOUT FATHERS TO MAKE LESS
THEMSELVES LATER IN LIFE.
FOR DECADES, THIS WAS A
RECOGNIZED PATTERN AND ENTER
CITIES.
THE CYCLE OF POVERTY.
MUCH IS WRITTEN ABOUT.
NOW THE SAME IS TRUE IN RURAL
AMERICA.
THE PROBLEM IS IN CULTURE.
IN BOTH CASES, THE CAUSE OF THE
SAME.
A LACK OF WELL-PAYING JOBS FOR
MEN.
WHAT'S STRIKING IS HOW LITTLE
NOTICE THESE FACTS GET FROM OUR
POLICYMAKERS.
THERE ARE OVER IS TO RAISE
WOMEN'S WAGES ABOVE MEN.
THERE IS NOTHING INHERENTLY
WRONG WITH THAT, BUT THESE ARE
COMPLEX QUESTIONS WITH NUMEROUS
AND PROFOUND UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES, SO THEY DESERVE A
VIGOROUS PUBLIC DEBATE.
IT'S NOTABLE THAT MOST WOMEN,
THE VERY POPULATION ON WHOSE
BEHALF THESE POLICIES ARE
SUPPOSEDLY DEVISED STRONGLY
PREFER TO MARRY MEN WHO MAKE